[Music]
okay guys i have a story
about this man named jimmy mcdonald
he was paddling on a kayak and
white yes alcohol yes
i just know when i hear it former
amateur boxer is how they describe them
jimmy mcdonald paddle boarding he's
white every time
former amateur boxer just sounds like a
backyard wrestler to me
that's how he labeled him that's not
important though the story here
is that he was pedaling in a kayak and
he was meditating taking photos all
alone
when he ended up drifting away from his
wife and his stepchildren
and so uh he wanted to get away from
them
he's like lord take me out of this place
and who
meditates on a kayak like what if
there's a waterfall in [ __ ]
i dropped the paddle that's like rule
number one right you just start drifting
away you gotta go where you see where
you're going i know i meditate with my
eyes open sometimes
i've never been a person named jimmy who
meditates though i know right jimmy
mcdonald that's confusing
anyway so as he was doing all that the
water around him became choppier
and so i want to wrap it up i could have
told him that he ended up like needing
to
pedal harder to keep going but then
that's when he ended up tipping
over and losing his paddle oh no
and so he was in approximately 30 feet
of
rough water and so he was fighting to
stay afloat so he had one hand on the
kayak and the other hand
keeping his smartphone above water which
i'm like what
do you have isn't it wait so he's doing
this thing but he's
he's like above water he didn't get the
insurance no also
the life jacket that he was wearing the
life vest
didn't fit him properly it was all all
the way up to his
neck like it wasn't like keeping him
afloat properly it was like all the way
up here
so he was struggling so then he said
that when people
pass by like some people pass by ask
like if they needed if he needed help
duh but he said that he had too much
pride
to ask for help he's like i got it
what i'm completely fine like [ __ ]
white white rappers over his head
like what is he people are watching like
that's a
that's an extreme guy okay yeah what
about the new sport looks like he got it
he's probably calling them [ __ ]
he had too much pride that's right that
sounds like a jimmy mcdonald oh yeah
i can't wait to scream him for my
amateur boxer yeah i can't wait to say
help man that's that's so
that's one of the most funnest things to
do is when you're in trouble when you go
help
dude and then people go i can i can
[ __ ] help you
when you're in trouble joe yelled for
help in the bedroom
help help this chicks aggressive
the neighbor comes oh [ __ ] for you
like thank you nate thank you please i i
need a break oh
i don't have no more calm left i needed
to drink a parched she didn't let me
drink any water for two days
she said suck your mouth on my butt
that's your hydration only wants to [ __ ]
this poor guy yeah
damn okay well so all that was happening
right
and then uh something happened
i'll let him tell you he deserves it if
it's bad he deserves it oh my [ __ ]
deer came and said you would grab my
antler
okay ready you know that's why i said
all right
i i think i might die today this might
be
it so i you know i prayed to my lord and
savior jesus christ for help so as soon
as i turned the boat towards him i
realized his life
preserver had been in the upper portion
of his head
he was hanging on for dear life how
funny is it that um
you know i've been sober for seven years
and
i get saved by a tiki bar for us
that was our mission it was a sign i got
a drink again
yeah so what ended up happening is this
tiki bar like this floating tiki bar
boat came closer because some what ended
up happening is he had a boat
this tiki bar was a boat full of
partying priests
and so so then they noticed that he
needed help so that's when
one of the priests heard him saying
jesus
so then they ended up like bringing him
onto the boat
and rescued him so he's saying like how
ironic is this i've been sober for
for seven years he's actually a drug
counselor and
he got saved by partying priests on a
tiki bar
he was praying was awesome he was like
and yeah they were a little handsy but i
was very appreciative
because they pulled me on board it
sounds like you know when like kids fall
in like shallow water and they freak the
[ __ ] out
and then the parent comes in and just
helps them stand up and they're like oh
it sounds like some [ __ ] like that right
because there's he's explaining it like
it's [ __ ] white
water [ __ ] smacking them everywhere
but then there's tikibot's just like
cruising
and there's other people going hey buddy
you need help he's like no
you know they're like why is he being so
dramatic why is he making his own white
water
just stand up dude yeah because i don't
picture a tiki bar riding
in the white water rapids yeah exactly
yeah it's coasting by
close enough to be able to pick them up
and they're not in trouble
he was just being a little [ __ ] dude
he's diving for pool sticks
in the six feet deep section and he's
like if my lord and savior jesus christ
could help me i swear i'll go to church
like two people went by being like you
need help he's like no no i got it
let's see he said no i'm waiting for the
alcohol he has enough time i mean he can
leave the phone and he has one hand on
the
put it inside the kayak no or flip the
kayak over if it's upside down i'm
waiting for the liquor boat
when's the liquor bowl put your phone in
your mouth if you really need to
i don't know i mean it's easy to
criticize from this
point that's what we do here we don't
know what the situation was
he he got a little drunk in the tiki bar
and his wife was like
where the [ __ ] are you oh my god and
he's like these good
fellas they rescued me i was gonna die i
was gonna die
she's like how's home your phone's not
wet then i was having it out like that
right he covered it and then she's like
this is amazing it's a miracle we got to
tell the news and he's like
sure yeah hey guys uh i know
you made a vow to not lie but can you
help a
fellow out yeah oh my god because
they're priests yeah that's [ __ ]
funny
so speaking of the priest here's one
being interviewed about this whole
situation i hope he's got a margarita in
his hand please
so here's the rest of the hawaiian shirt
on too to match yeah
that was our mission to be to be present
to and to help
someone in need and i just take that as
a sign from god that you know
um you know he's got me here for a real
reason
no bro i think he was trying to get rid
of you in your ass
somehow the devil helped your dumb ass
out i think it was a sign from god that
mega margaritas is my dream
wait was the other preacher in a
hawaiian shirt too
uh no that was the guy who captained
that
cabinet he was the one yeah
the captain i mean if a tiki boat
can be in this river it's probably calm
as [ __ ]
this is why i love the news okay people
love to hate on the news okay
but for every 1 000 stories you find a
diamond in the rough like this
i feel like every single time you have
somebody
that is like um what do you call it like
you know like
explaining what happened to their
neighbor or it's always like this
yeah they were they were just normal and
then when they find like someone's been
murdered in the house or like there's a
drug operation they're like
they always never bothered anyone
exactly
and it's like a dude with like two teeth
or some [ __ ] and
every time anyway it did make it to the
news the story here about jimmy
and he everyone really liked it because
it's like
like that's amazing he got saved but not
not only did he get saved he got saved
by
priests that just so happened to be
floating by
in a tiki boat at the bar after he had
been sober for seven years yeah
and he's a drug count there's just so
much irony all right priests drinking
can they drink
take a party so they drink the body of
christ a lot all the time they drink the
body they said that they were invited
for this free ride
we didn't drink we didn't day drink
parentheses
much and we we were we were ready to
save at any moment
we're drinking the blood are they not
allowed to drink
because i'd like save like this like
whatever what did they do no because
drinking the blood is drinking wine
right
yes the blood of christ is wine they
can't drink alcohol
they can't oh i don't know i was asking
i was posing the question oh
i don't know what about all the chicks
are on the boat it's all jumped off real
quick
probably like oh [ __ ] you're partying
party with all the men's like get off
your [ __ ] house yeah no i'll get
jumped off
yeah well we don't know oh what a weird
story let's be real if it's the church
it was not
chicken yeah it was like boys yeah it
was the boys yeah yeah
the candle boys right here there you go
they were the ones on the boat who
rescued me that's cool
he is a he's a very interesting person
all the boxers out there like
dude why do you give your boxers a bad
name dude like do they have to label him
as that mature former
boxer yeah they're like dude you're
supposed to be there now you think all
amateur boxers are [ __ ] they should
have labeled him as
a counselor who got saved or whatever
that's my druggies his pride was like
i'm a former amateur boxer
correct probably not not a drunk count
like drug counselor
drunk a drunk counselor
you're an alcoholic i get saved by
alcoholics i'm a drunk i'm a drunk
counselor
hey so like what yeah like what's your
situation like what's going on
all right [ __ ] it just put the money on
the counter yeah yeah
no he seems like he's a he's a from his
interview he seems like he's a good guy
he was just like you know what this was
a sign from
a sign from god that he really kept me
here for a reason which is to help
the people he's counseling what if it
was the the reporter that did this
because they're like what are you a drug
a drug counselor oh that's boring what
else did you do
yeah uh give a second i'm sexy i used to
box with my friends
you're a former amateur boxer no not
really i mean i just did in the backyard
a couple times okay
you're a former amateur boxer you were
we just did wwe moves in the backyard
all right yeah oh
boxer you're a tough guy a tough guy
who's afraid to admit
that he's weak yep how about that how do
you
how do you have rapid moving water on
the lake
i don't know why i don't
maybe making the water a little choppy
it even looked like there were buoys
like
he was inside the ropes not to get too
serious but tell it to [ __ ] naia
rivera bro
who's that the glee actress exactly she
died she
got a robot with her son very recently
she just went out for an afternoon she
got assassinated that's why
no she she just went out for an
afternoon row i guess he called a row
and then um they decided to jump in the
water together and then the boat
i think got away from them due to the
current and she was only able to scoop
her son back on the boat in time that
she drowned and her son was too dumb to
row it oh he was four years old
and they both didn't have life vests so
so she
didn't request the life vest but the
person gave them a life vest and i don't
think she wore it
obviously because it took her three days
to find her body
oh yeah oh she she got tired huh she got
tired yeah
because the you know when you're in even
something you think is still water
wasn't there some sort of like theory
that she
might have purposely done that because
of the
the thing that she had tweeted out
before which was an eminem
quote excuse me yeah it was remember i
told you
it was an eminem lyric oh it was from
just the two of us
yeah but what's the song about well the
song is about him murdering his wife and
then dumping her body in a lake with his
his little uh daughter holy [ __ ]
that's literally what happened yes
that's right what was the quote though
i don't know i don't remember oh i don't
know i just remember you i said it was
from that song yes i forgot the exact
quote
i think it i think it was just the two
of the two of us it said something like
that
so they're linking it to that song it's
very vague
we don't know if it is exactly it could
just be hopefully it's the just the two
of us we can make it if we try
one yeah bill withers just the two of us
and not the sample one within them
yes yeah exactly just the two of us
slash eminem like when you used to
download music
okay so people just assumed it was
eminem
yeah oh because if it was thank god oh
good lord yeah
good luck good lord but so was [ __ ]
sad so [ __ ] sad
and and apparently she had gotten
tangled up in like the
there's like a foliage underwater oh
and so that's what kept her body from
rising there's kelp yeah
some sort of plants down jump in this
water like thinking it's a lake
like you don't know what you're getting
into necessarily there's just one scary
movie that i watched where like
the killer would wrap the corpses with
the
underwater seaweed or whatever and they
were all like it was like a
garden of dead bodies under there yeah
but how long does that last because then
aren't there like bugs and
and fish that come and eat it you think
yeah
oh i just googled like recent about her
uh nia rivera and it says that her son
recounts
like the last thing that she he told she
told him which was that
he heard her yell help yeah i heard that
oh
very sad help and then she went under
apparently
um so have a good rest of the day there
out there no this is our last episode of
the day so now we're walking away from
this office
hey go get the travis scott meal okay
take it easy tonight
well bringing it back to jimmy here
jimmy does
say that uh like his his advice out
there for the people
is to encourage others to wear their
life vest the correct way
to test them before they head out and to
not go alone yes
love it i thought that's the advice they
always give you
yeah but and don't wear the life vest on
your head or just do any good
like you have to make sure it properly
fits apparently he didn't do that
and listen i've been playing pirate game
with your son
you play power cam oh on steam a video
game you got to put the [ __ ] anchor
down
before you get on the island okay so
some boats don't have anything so both
well she should have had an anchor a
little bit maybe get like a toaster and
just
throw it off that's crazy i wouldn't
abandon the boat
and swim around it without anchoring
someone on the boat
like being on dry land before would you
naturally think that like oh a lake
could take my boat away like
yeah i wouldn't think that i would
really yeah because there's wind that
can push it away
yeah i wouldn't think that there was a
king of queens episode where kevin james
got stuck in the middle lake
because of that
[Music]
you